what hi youtube this is dan shapiro from
the Harvard international negotiation
initiative I'm also director of the
World Economic Forum's Global Agenda
Council on negotiation and conflict
resolution this council is a multi
stakeholder group of former heads of
state major actors negotiators working
to help people deal with their
differences more effectively at Davos
we've been sharing with the community
here some of the major insights that
we've been working on and in practical
advice that we are working to spread
around the world in terms of how to make
our world a safer place and I think this
is really important information to be
share and basically one year ago the
world had very little sense of the
impending global economic crisis and
there's consensus among many within the
international security realm at least
some that there's another incipient
crisis right around right around the
corner and that is the crisis of
international security how do we keep
ourselves safe from terrorism from from
nuclear proliferation and from violent
conflict and what we've realized is that
the nature of conflict has changed
significantly over the past 15 20 years
and indeed we found that there's a lot
more interesting conflict conflict
within States regional conflict than
interstate conflict additionally there's
been more fragmentation so we're finding
increasing divisions within rebel
movements governments for example in the
DRC and elsewhere and on and on a number
of different ways that conflict has
changed in our world the question though
is ultimately how are we going to deal
with conflict large-scale violent
conflict in our world most effectively
and this is a tough question there are a
tremendous number of people working hard
to deal with the situation around the
world literally from our own perspective
a couple of key points come out first of
all there's something we call the
prevention principle it's incredibly
important for the international
community working in issues of crisis
management conflict resolution to focus
at the smallest level most local level
possible at the earliest moment possible
what can we be doing today to prevent
the emergence of violent
conflict in the future I mean who can be
doing what now we should be pressuring
our government leaders to take action
now yes the economy is critically
important but if we only focus on the
economy then we are leaving a very
fragile world where fragile states are
going to become very chaotic States and
in this borderless world we will all be
victim to those kinds of complexities of
our world secondly we've been talking
about the importance of talk of
negotiation and it's in many ways
obviously important when people have
differences to talk about those
differences yet it doesn't always happen
in the international spectrum especially
with so many different kinds of actors
non-state actors and it's our belief
I'll speak personally it's my belief
that that is extremely important to talk
especially to those we consider your
enemy if your goal is ultimately peace
and talking in today's world we've also
realized has its great complexities
talking isn't simply picking up a phone
anymore it can be but even picking up a
phone is increasing increasingly a part
of the complexity of negotiation when we
have cell phones when we have rebel
movements in hard-to-reach locations
using the cell phone exploiting to the
use of the cell phone for example how
can we use technology most effectively
to help it foster talk a third area that
we've been focusing on within our
councils importance of bringing women
into the peace making process there are
some but not many involved in the
peacemaking process the UN has been
working to promote that and we as well
are trying to promote the importance of
bringing women into the dialogue process
into the peacemaking processes and
finally this is one that hits me very
close to home it's the importance of
dealing with the emotional and
identity-based dimensions to conflict
conflict obviously involves Catholic
resolution many different elements and
one of the most important when we have
interesting conflicts and regional
conference is how do you deal with these
emotional identity-based issues we don't
have the skills we don't have the tools
right now
to deal with those complexities there's
there are certainly people out there
doing good work in this realm those in
transitional justice people doing work
on how to deal with trauma but when I
look at the situation in Gaza it
frightens me it saddens me in so many
ways partially because we don't as a
world community know how effectively to
deal with these kinds of situations and
it's imperative to develop new ideas new
practical ideas to deal with them that's
part of my own work at the harvard
international negotiation initiative
what we're doing in any case of youtube
i know this was a mouthful but i look
forward to continued conversation with
you on the subject matter thanks so much
for listening